hey everybody
time for another movie review going back
to the 70s nature run amuck
one of my favorite actually that's one
of my favorite uh sub genres
especially from the 1970s because there
were so many like
cheesy nature run amok movies my dad
took me damn drive in to see this one
this one and that
you know what it was it was this one and
i think battle among the stars remember
japanese yeah yeah yeah it was a double
feature
at the drive-in but i started i was
probably about what
nine yeah this came out in 78 so you
would have been yeah i started
man i started [ __ ] getting really
upset about this piranha eating those
dudes
legs off and chewing people's hands off
whenever his hand was getting
eaten up and the little boy was watching
i was like
[Laughter]
we gotta go and i remember this movie
being
[ __ ] terrible like real low budget no
it was awesome
it's pretty [ __ ] good we saw the
original
and then after that we saw the um the
1995
remake i guess it's made for tv if you
look at it it was yeah
and it was almost [ __ ] frame for
frame the same movie with the tighter
edit it was good it was even better in a
way
yeah the original was the original
second yeah because i think the original
had more of like
had comedy in it and like the remake not
so much
you know what i mean these are basically
jaws rip-offs yeah it's riding on the
back of the jaws
[ __ ] thing but um
what what was it george lucas saw this
right there
steven spiel steven spielberg saw this
movie liked it
yeah he said it and actually i want to
get into that he said this was his
favorite of the jaws robots
yeah it's good it was a lot better than
i remembered and you can you can get it
basically for free on online didn't we
see this on tuesday it's on to be uh the
1978 one which is the one we made
mainly talking about and the 1995 remake
which i didn't even know existed like i
said that was made for tv
and that's also on to be there was also
another
actually the first piranha that came out
in 1978 that had a sequel called piranha
to the spawning
um which i don't i think i saw it but i
don't really remember anything about it
but in 2010 they did a remake called
piranha 3d
that's supposed to be it was um what's
his name uh
alexandra aja that french like extreme
director or whatever
and it's supposed to be like balls to
the wall insane like [ __ ]
a piranha like biting the dude's penis
off and then fitting the penis back in
the camera
like that and it's like super bloody and
then i think they made a sequel to that
which was called
piranha three double d um because there
was a bunch of shrimp percentage yeah
okay so that was 2010 2011.
we're gonna see down like you it's like
oh you parked my android yeah yeah well
yeah i was gonna say something about it
you know that we can add this one to the
[ __ ] encyclopedia of boobology
it was the the movie is packed it now
has a good story
it's got [ __ ] heather menzies in it
who is the girl who played jessica from
the [ __ ] from logan's
logan's ron television series who she's
kind of like the budget fair faucet even
though i like her she's cute
she can act but she's kind of like the
budget for her faucet and she's playing
opposite like a leading man who's i
don't know what dude's name is
bradford dillman bradford he's
definitely
the uh the budget [ __ ] um
yeah charlene heston and i've also seen
like a couple reviews called them like
the brawny man as well because he's
wearing that
he's got that beard and he's got that
like lumberjack kind of yeah that's what
the kind of action
that's what they did back in the 70s the
men were [ __ ] manly manly man
compared to mustache and he was all
cranky and great oh don't talk to me i'm
a man
no i'm not interested in you that's good
humor and good writing
no i'm too manly i don't want to sleep
you know
you suck it's pretty easy he's like that
you know plus he's a drunk which i love
that
yeah there's a lot of good elements in
the movie there was a sci-fi element
that i had
i didn't pick up when i was a kid little
mini dinosaurs and [ __ ] weird [ __ ]
and military experiments gone
wild yeah it didn't follow up on much
you know what the story behind that was
okay so as i said this came out in 1978
it was directed by
joe dante one of his very early films uh
obviously he went on to do gremlins and
the howling and
inner space and [ __ ] you know all
that stuff
and it was produced by roger corman so i
think this was like his second movie now
what um joe dante because you know he's
very well known for putting humor into
his
movies the howling had humor in it
gremlins had humor yeah it was good
humor good timing
yeah yeah what he wanted to do the
little monster because a lot of people
have complained about there was there's
like a little stop-motion monster when
they first go into the lab
you know what i mean like where the like
where'd that thing go yeah and it's like
and they only show it once
well what happened was joe dante wanted
that to be in there like as an homage to
ray harryhausen like the old like
monster films
and his original plan was that over the
course of the movie that monster would
get bigger and bigger
and like in the background and then like
at the end it was just gonna like eat up
here or something like that and like
have nobody talk about it
but in the end they didn't have enough
budget to pull it off so he just like
left that in there because he thought it
was cool but like he couldn't do exactly
what he wanted to do with it so he did
have a plan for it but
yeah it just it didn't come to fruition
yeah um there was a lot of good
underwater shots good special effects
it's like it's filmed well
uh i guess it's been restored it looks
new or you know look
it it looks fresh it doesn't look new
yeah it looks like something on the 70s
but it's done it's done real well and
there's a lot of 70s
cultural stuff you know what i mean like
just it's just packed with [ __ ]
they're wearing bikinis and tube tops
and there's all kinds of nip slips and
they do a fake heather knit a heather
memsey's [ __ ] boob shot
you can tell they edit it yeah it's not
a body though
but they try to give the audience of the
time what they wanted you know it's it's
it's a jaws rip-off so there's always
you know girls in bikinis and um
and you know everybody's pretty pretty
fit for the time you know
uh they had some hotties so i can drive
them power boats and
people with [ __ ] you know skiing
behind power boats and getting eaten by
piranhas and
good effects good practical effects yeah
i mean for 1978 these were pretty decent
because i remember
seeing this as a kid i mean i would have
only been
six years old when it came out so i
probably didn't see it
in the theater yeah um i might have seen
it a couple years later like at a
uh you know at a drive-in or i might
have just seen it on cable
i have to say that this movie because
you know i'm really scared of sharks and
like you know underwater [ __ ] in general
so this movie like scared the [ __ ] out
of me too when i was a kid um
this movie because i feel like oh say so
jaws came out in 1975 and then after
that
it was just kind of like a non-stop
cavalcade
of kind of has been actors that used to
be like really really famous and then
they would be in all these kind of
nature runabox which was orca which is
another one of my uh favorite ones it
was grizzly
um the animals although that might have
been before that it was like the swarm i
think that was later like oh
yeah i remember the alligator i remember
i remember the trailers for the swarm we
gotta see that one
yeah i haven't seen that you know
bringing it back memories yeah the
kingdom of the spiders
yeah there was a [ __ ] a prophecy the one
about the weird
mutant bear i liked that one i did too i
like that
like i said i really really like that uh
that [ __ ] uh
genre you know what i mean i i i
i'm [ __ ] i was kind of stunned i
think if i was uh you know like i was
nine or ten when i saw it
had i seen this at 12 i would have liked
it yeah i think i had not really gotten
to the point where i could process what
was going on
could you know i don't know there was it
scared me at nine i was like man
this is [ __ ] scary i can't handle
this um
but i think i had already seen alien by
then bang
it's hard to say it's hard to say well
this came out a year before
okay no no then i know i saw that when
it came out yeah because when i saw
alien i [ __ ] loved it
yeah um yeah i just don't think my brain
was
uh developed enough at the time seeing
it
as a kid to really understand what was
going on i only saw like maybe the first
one quarter of it i would have liked the
whole sled angle and everything
i'd say slept with much love in my heart
but in the 70s a [ __ ] was just a woman
who
a young woman who owned her person owned
her own sexuality
she did she did what she wanted to do
yeah they were sexual aggressors a lot
that was that was real
cool back then you know looking and
there's is some of that
in there in here references to that to
the way it was back then
kind of neat yeah and the thing about i
mean they got i had forgotten
because like i said i don't think i saw
this since i was a kid and i had
forgotten
what a [ __ ] fantastic cast they got
from yes
it's all star so like like i said stars
yeah well bradford dillman who was in it
we just saw him in that movie bug
not too long ago he was the same guy
yeah now he was actually i looked up his
wikipedia page because he was in a ton
of
kind of b movies around this time period
but he started out on broadway
and then he was in like a really lot of
um he won all kind of awards like he was
in like some really well regarded movies
and tv shows like back in the day and
then he sort of wanted to be movies
later on
um heather menzies as we mentioned he
was on the logan's run tv show
she i think she was on the captain
america show as well in the late 70s
she's cute
she's cute uh kevin mccarthy is in this
who was in the original invasion of the
body snatchers from 1956
and he was in twilight zone the movie
keenan nguyen is [ __ ] in this he was
dr strangelove in doctor strangelove
and i remember him from laser blast
because that was that was a terrible
with the turtle aliens
uh that was on mystery science theater
barbara steele is in it
i had forgotten barbara steele was in it
she's only in the end and dick miller
who i think was in everything roger
corman ever made
yeah uh he's just in every [ __ ] and
he does all the comedic relief
yeah and he was and he was in uh
gremlins and stuff as well
like later on what's funny is that
movies of this era
the sci-fi slash [ __ ] genre they all
had the same ending like this and like
bug
yeah where it just ends okay done we won
and then they're like don't think about
it too immediately
like wait what the hell happened that's
how it ended yeah yeah that's
that's just how they did it back in the
70s sometimes there was no wind
down or a wrap up yeah they're just kind
of like blew up october
wait a minute it's a high impact ending
yeah
that's how a director back then this
movie it's like i had forgotten
like i said i had forgotten how
everybody in it was famous
and i also forgot how funny it was
and it's it's funny in a good way like
in the way that joe dante's
done dante's stuff is like yeah it's not
like
wacky or zany or anything it's but it's
not dry
either it's just like a good like
situational humor yeah like
there's a part where [ __ ] heather is
like she gets she's in
she gets locked up in a jail cell with
some dude and he [ __ ] with her and he
they're trying to have to escape the
police station to go save the world
and she [ __ ] beats a dude over the
head of the toilet seat wouldn't it
knocks his ass out yeah then she has
wants to get in his clothes for some
reason well no she needs to get the keys
off and the keys are chained to his
pants
that's right so she has to pull his
[ __ ] pants off to get the keys
and [ __ ] dudes in the other cell
going you're going going come on
i thought you could get a man's pants
off faster
i'm fine yeah this is [ __ ]
sexual humor in it well yeah it was it's
just funny [ __ ] so
basically so what happens in this
there's a there's a short um
you know sequence at the beginning with
your kind of
obligatory stupid uh
teenagers kind of you know backpacking
through the woods or whatever
and they're like hey no trespassing sign
at a military site that we're clearly
not supposed to go into let's go in here
and jump into this random ass pool of
water that you can't even see to the
bottom of
they get eaten up and of course they get
eaten yeah so uh but that's what sets
the plot in motion and
and honestly this movie the quality of
it is much much better than i remembered
i remembered it being just like a super
cheesy throwaway stupid
i'm not saying it's like you know
citizen kane or anything i thought it
was going to be like on par with giant
spider invasion that's how i remembered
it
yeah as bad as giant spider yeah it's
not
it's not it's a lot tighter a lot better
production yeah you can tell that some
that people like competent people made
this movie yeah i mean
it was like you could tell that they
were trying to make something like jaws
at that level you know not quite i mean
they're expensive but
i mean this is close this costs maybe 60
thousand dollars
600 600 000 cost 600 000
because the special effects are pretty
good they even reused a lot of them in
the [ __ ] remake yeah i kind of want
to get it
under water well yeah the thing about it
is like you can tell like for 1978
these uh special effects are actually
not bad it's like yeah you can tell that
the fish like
you know in the wide shots like where
there's a little school of them like
coming through you can tell they're not
real
obviously but the close-up shots where
they're attacking somebody
and like they just have blood in the
water and it's all like that horrible
like uh
sound effect and then you can see like
all the little fish biting in like
little
chunks coming off and there's a couple
shots in there where
you basically you see a piranha like
bite someone's
tit or their nipple or something like
that so that's because did you see it
yeah so he called it out he got her
nipple
got it and then i was like oh that would
that would suck
but yeah and then there was one too i i
one of my favorite shots i think the one
that freaked me out when i was a kid
was the one they show a foot and there's
like three um
you know there's three piranhas like at
the foot like that and it
looks real yeah you know what i mean so
it really does look like somebody
yeah i know i remembered it being about
about just normal piranhas which is
[ __ ] crazy
if you know anything about piranhas
they're they're nowhere near as
dangerous as people who want to want to
blow you know jeremy wade sat in a hole
yeah
long time i was just like yeah you can
even put a [ __ ] little bit of
you can even cut yourself and put some
blood in the water and they'll take
interest but they won't go crazy
um but uh no they're not normal piranhas
they're genetic experiments they were
going to use them in vietnam
yeah they were going to use them as a
weapon in vietnam somehow
uh well they were gonna i guess
everybody that went into the river would
get
eaten up yeah i don't know how you win a
war these piranhas
had been blood they they weren't like
bigger than regular piranhas
yeah but they were intelligent they were
kind of smarter than regular piranhas
which probably isn't that hard to do
um they bred faster they were more
aggressive right
like a hive mentality and they could
live in fresh water or salt water
yeah which like i said that's not crazy
that's not an out loud
outlandish i mean it's it's perfectly
fine for like a 70s
animals attack movie you could probably
attempt it today but like i said that
would not be a war winning weapon it'd
be wasted
well no money but they didn't end up
using it so it's like so kevin mccarthy
plays the doctor that was working on it
and basically what ended up happening is
like well
we you know the war ended before we
perfected the [ __ ] we didn't get to use
it so we're just keeping them for
whatever reason
like up at this sort of abandoned
facility and
so the two kids who go missing at the
beginning of the movie because they
stupidly jump into this [ __ ]
pool in the middle of the woods and get
eaten by and probably rightfully though
um so heather menzies she's a skip
tracer
and she gets hired to go find them like
by the girl's dad or something like that
so she tracks them to there finds their
clothes and jewelry and figures oh they
were here
and maybe they drowned in this pond so
she goes to drain the pond
thereby releasing all of the piranhas
into the
uh attached river system and it's gonna
go downstream there's like
um a kids can summer camp at which
uh bradford dillman's daughter is there
and then further down there's a new like
lake resort which is run by dick
miller's character
so they're putting a lot of people in
the way of where these piranhas are
going and fair play to this movie
it is not afraid to have a whole bunch
of
eight-year-olds eaten yeah hi
fantastic eight-year-old
[Laughter]
the eight-year-olds are on top of
[ __ ] inner tubes and [ __ ] trying to
do heroic
[ __ ] things like save one another and
everything with the water all
froth and insurance blood and stuff
that's pretty good man that's pretty
good
i liked it maybe that's why maybe that's
why my dad got me out of there when i
was getting i guess i might have been
eight
maybe because little kids were getting
eaten i don't remember exactly when we
left yeah because i mean that happens
like i've been
pretty late in the movie that's kind of
like because the one thing that this
movie does that's really good
is it really kind of builds up the
character and the story and everything
like that before all the carnage
occurs like some people do get killed
early like keenan wins character
um he is kind of like sitting on the
dock and he's kind of drinking with his
dog or whatever and the
you know the piranha come and like gnaw
his like the bottom parts of his legs
off which is actually like a really good
looking effect and he then he bleeds to
death so it's like that's kind of how
they
sort of follow the trail of the piranhas
as they go down the river
and then you know it just gets gets
ramped up and ramped up because it's
like oh there's all these kids down
there and then farther down the river
there's even more tourists
because it's kind of like a jaws thing
where it's like no we're gonna open the
[ __ ] anyway
even though you know they got warned
about it and so
like i said so it's really cool that
they just
went for it and like had all these
little kids get killed
um you know except for bradford dilman's
daughter who i think her
character's name is susie in the movie
and she's the only smart one in the
summer camp and she's just like i don't
want to go in the water there's like
stuff in there and i'm just like
with the right you are there is stuff in
there and that's why the only she's the
only one that didn't get [ __ ] chewed
on that's why
but you know what i'm saying so yeah so
the funny thing about this is that what
initially happened with this movie when
it was going to come out in 1978
universal studios um their
jaws 2 was coming out this same summer
right
so they were trying to sue
the makers of piranha like to keep it
from coming they were saying like
copyright infringement or some [ __ ]
like that
yeah that close to jobs even though well
and the thing about it too is that i
from what i've heard it might have been
that some of the universal executives
um thought that piranha might be a
better movie than john's 2
and we're like so we're trying to like
suppress it a little bit but steven
spielberg went to bat
for this movie because he saw it and he
liked it so he went to universal and
said hey man like knock it off it's
you know it's perfectly fine movie is it
you know is it a jaw's rip off
not really i mean it's yeah because
sci-fi angle though because it's
fish and it's attacking but it's it's
but it's not like a jaws rip off in the
same way that say like devil fish that
italian movie or
orca or something like that which is
more one big thing it's like i i feel
like there's not really you can't really
have a copyright on
you know oh an ex-animal attacks people
you know whatever animal attacks because
it had it had a lot more of a damn
sci-fi angle to it than jaws yeah
because they were genetically modified
and it had a monster movie feel to it so
it was not like jaws really same kind of
situation
yeah trying to protect civilians from
these things
but and there are a lot of beach shots
you know
yeah motorboats and [ __ ] motor boats
blowing up they were good stunts
it's actually a good movie a lot of good
underwater shots guy trying to open a
valve underneath the water
when the damn piranhas are eating him up
you know just it it had
in some ways better stuff
or better ideas than jaws had because
well if you think kind of over the top
or outlandish is better i mean it had a
monster in it
yeah you know a little [ __ ] tiny
dinosaur and weird looking damn eels
that were
looking at you and i loved that idea
though because i didn't realize because
we saw it too because we were like well
what happened with the little stop
motion
yeah dinosaur thing or whatever that was
and that yeah
and the eel that was like the thing and
it looks like it was intelligent
watching you
yeah so when i read that it's like that
he had an idea for it and he was like
yeah it was supposed to get bigger and
bigger but like no one was going to
comment on it it was going to be like in
the background and then you'd just see
it like dropping around and then it got
bigger and i was like oh my god that
would have been an
awesome idea yeah but he just couldn't
do it he just couldn't do it
so yeah so i i just kind of feel like
another interesting thing about this
movie too is that
this is one of the few i don't even even
know if i can think of another movie
like this maybe from back in the 50s
but this is kind of like one of the only
nature run amok movies
where they basically kill the piranhas
by or do they
by uh intentionally polluting the river
yeah
basically they just like put all they
said there's like it'll just kill
everything
although there is a hint at the end that
um and they did make a sequel
there is a hint at the end that the uh
piranha did end up escaping to the ocean
which was what they were trying to
keep from happening because they're like
because they breed so fast and
you know they'll just wipe out
everything in the ocean which i don't
imagine they would because they're not
big but you know
the only other thing that was kind of
like this would be like cross between
jaws and remember food of the gods yeah
kind of like that very loosely based on
an h.g wells story yes something like
that
i wonder yeah i wanted to say too so
like i said you can tell that competent
people made this so joe dante directed
it
um and i think this steven spielberg
going to bat for this movie
might have been one of the things that
you know that made the two of them
friends which
you know kind of got joe dante like
gremlins and stuff later on
also the writer on this was john sales
for christ's sake who
he did alligator too later um but then
he did he did the first version of the
script of e.t
for christ's sake uh i think he went on
he did like apollo 13
and so he did like really big movies
like later on so this was one of his
early writing credits
now last night we were watching this
movie like i said it's on tubey
and i hadn't seen it since i was a kid
so we really so we like watched that we
got some we
had some beers and we were watching this
and then we saw in toby that it's like
oh they have the 1995 version as well
which i didn't even know there was one i
had heard that there was one from the
from 2010 2011 and it was shorter
yeah it's funny it's and you can tell
because we watched so we were like [ __ ]
it we were kind of like half
liquored up so we were like [ __ ] it
let's watch the 1995 one as well and we
can talk about that too
now the interesting thing about it is
that they used
pretty much the exact same script like a
lot of the dialogue is exactly the same
um you know most of the gags are the
same
and they even reused all the underwater
footage
from the first one which still worked
which still yeah but you know
it was made for tv so like i said it's
in that [ __ ] weird aspect ratio
yeah but this one was also kind of
good yeah it was also it they kind of
took a lot of the humor out you can tell
they took out some of the scenes where
like they took out the funny [ __ ]
in the original with bradford dillman
like being a drunk and with keenan
nguyen like bringing him all the liquor
and he's like oh i got tequila i got
bourbon i got this i got that and it was
like funny that he was drunk you know
what i mean which i thought was
funny anyway he was like this cranky you
know alcoholic
um so they took all that character
development out they took a lot of the
jokes out
um but they tightened it up a lot so
it's a so the 1995 one's only an hour
and 20 minutes
and i think that the original was more
like an hour
and 32 minutes 35 minutes something like
that so they took like 12 to 15 minutes
out of it and if you watch them back to
back you can see
exactly the scenes that they took out
because the scenes are pretty much
exactly in the same order
and are it's almost a shot for shot
remake
i have to say and it's interesting too
because
there's a lot of really famous people in
uh the 1995 one too
you got in the bradford dillman role you
got william cat
uh who had been he was in house he was
greatest american hero
you know back in the 80s you got uh
alexandra paul
who was uh arnie's girlfriend in
christine
uh in 1983. yeah you don't believe that
i couldn't really recognize her because
her hair was so much
shorter yeah she's still cute though but
she
looked real kind of sleek and 90s
looking it doesn't it you know
she didn't have yeah she didn't have
that big poofy like feathery hair like
she had in uh christine
but yeah she's in that also a very very
young
uh what's her name uh mila kunis
whatever her name is like uh
she she played a kid in this like she
played uh the daughter
you know what i mean susie and also sole
moon fry better known as punky brewster
was in this she'd grown up some by this
uh time because this was 1995 she played
20. yeah she played one of the uh camp
counselors like one of the
parts that you know was in the first one
so it's like it's really really funny
how
but it was really interesting to watch
them back to back because
not only did i recognize all of the
you know footage because roger corman
directed or produced the second one
too so he was just like well why shoot
all these underwater
scenes again because you know how budget
conscious roger gorman is
so he's just kind of like man this is
still good we'll just use that instead
we'll just kind of make it match
and it did actually kind of match i
think that if i hadn't just watched the
original
i might not have realized that it was
the same footage again
but i just thought it was weird how i
mean the dialogue was almost exactly the
same yeah yeah
the same movie it's just tighter and and
it's almost shot for shot the same but
the angle might be a little bit
different the set you know where they
are
you know i mean the setting is different
it's not in the same place
yeah but it is the same story oh yeah
yes definitely
it's exactly the same and it's just
tightened up for television and uh
it was also good it wasn't bad yeah not
bad at all it just it really seems like
um
you know if you're going to make the
exact same movie it seemed a little
weird like
i don't know i don't want to say first
the first one was forgotten by this time
probably because this is a you know
the original is a forgotten movie not
really it's kind of it's pretty much
well yeah but i mean it's a cult classic
though yeah i didn't know it was a cult
classic i never heard it it is
yeah never heard it mentioned i saw it
in the theater when it was new
forgot all about it and like i said they
just made a 3d remake in 2010
i think it was and that got a sequel as
well i've never even heard people
mention this movie
yeah i remembered it it made a big
impression on me as a kid because like i
said you know
getting eaten yeah well because i grew
up you know in daytona beach i
grew up like right on the atlantic ocean
and i was at the beach all the time so
it's like i was really freaked out by
you know sharks and plots i'm from
florida so i'm really freaked out by
alligators we need to do the movie
alligator too because that movie also
scared
the [ __ ] out of me when i was a kid
because like i couldn't think of
when i was a kid i couldn't think of
anything worse than getting eaten
by a big animal like and knowing that
you were getting eaten by a big animal
that's just like a horrifying concept to
me yeah that one scene where the guys
in the first version the first version
if you ask me is the one you want to see
well yeah it's a lot more classic it's
it's better
it has that 70s charm it's kind of has a
little more meandering it's a little
funnier
it's funnier it's [ __ ] it's funnier
yeah it's better
although the woman better tone the woman
in the 90s one
uh that at the very beginning who jumps
in the pool you know what i mean
she had a much bigger rack yeah than the
girl in the big original one well they
that was it was implants yeah
the 70s girls are all now they're all
natural yeah they're all down
and pushing everything yeah and then but
what
what i remembered about it as a kid is
uh the guy's hand
getting stuck down the water with his
kid watching him on the canoe and the
[ __ ]
piranhas eating his hand the other guy
that got it was
so drunk he couldn't get his feet out of
the water and his feet are hanging in
the water in the [ __ ] piranhas
eight is eating from the knee down yeah
well that's horrifying
that scene right there you know going to
uh mississippi
and [ __ ] seeing my dad every summer a
little kid
putting your feet out over over the end
of a docks or over the end of a boat
into the water
i'd do it and for a few minutes and then
remember that movie going
never mind
but i wasn't so much afraid of piranhas
doing it because i knew there weren't
any piranhas there i was afraid of an
alligator gar coming up and
biting me well yeah or a snapping turtle
if you guys don't know what an alligator
gar is it's a big old eel-like
primitive fish half of it is [ __ ]
head it's just a long
head with needle sharp [ __ ] teeth
they're not aggressive but
it looks like they could bite you they
look mean they look real mean they're
not though
it's kind of like barracuda like they
look well barracuda can't
r can be pretty mean well and barracuda
too will also jump into your boat
they'll jump in yet yeah
so you know they're in nature they're
kind of mellow and chilled out they just
catch fish
and they're not they're not real uh
they're not they're actually not the
kind of thing to come up and bite you
and they don't they're not very strong
anyway they're kind of slow
i wonder if anybody i mean there must be
in this day and age when they've
pretty much mined every single animal
for a
sci-fi original movie but i wonder if
they've made a movie about an alligator
gar
that's just called gar well i saw
photographs
in in louisiana of [ __ ] big old flat
paddle boat looking things
that can go through the swamp yeah and
they had an electrified front end on
them
and they were out there killing gar now
this was in the early 1900s
okay maybe like the 20s the 30s they
were trying to exterminate gar
you can google it and
they describe a very different gar than
i knew
they said that they were huge and that
they were aggressive and maybe back in
those days some of those guard might
have been
upward from 100 years old maybe they got
very very big when they were old
yeah they're not that old anymore you
know they don't live as long as they
used to i guess
yeah i think i saw some in well one like
river or something like that that i was
swimming and i saw some just kind of
chilling out over there and they were
maybe
three or four feet long yeah no they
were saying that these were could get up
to like
nine to 12 feet long and i've never seen
one that big no i haven't either and
but it may have been dudes just trying
to make money
off of killing them because they were it
was companies that were hired by the
state to go out and kill these things
and uh
maybe they maybe they were just judging
them on how they looked
and maybe the guys actually went out and
killed them knew that they were kind of
harmless but they want
they wouldn't tell the local you know
the local governments that they were
harmless they did
the cash would stop flowing well yeah
they weren't they're not any good to eat
no no it's garbage fish yeah but yeah
that's
so that's the thing so so like i said i
kind of feel like
this movie i'm just really really glad i
got to watch it again because i
remembered i remembered it scaring me
when i was little
but i also remembered it being kind of
like a shitty
throwaway super cheap movie and it was a
super cheap movie
but it doesn't really look like it i
mean the writing is actually really good
it's actually
like pretty funny but all the actors are
totally are really good in it
it's got a really good cast um it's just
i don't know it's just like early
spielberg movies yeah it's like actually
much much better than i remembered it
being and the piranha effects for this
being such a low budget movie and it
being the late 70s are actually pretty
effective i thought
i forgot about the sci-fi angle yeah
like the genetics
yeah and that it being a military weapon
yeah and i kind of chuckle at that
although
yeah but it makes sense so there's only
one
military weapon that based on animals
that ever [ __ ] had any promise for
success you guys can look it up it was
called the bat
the batters are gonna say the bat bomb
the bat bomb worked
it was bomb you dropped then on its way
down it opened up and on a parachute and
in there on these little racks were
these
hibernating bats they had been kind of
you make them real cold with dry eyes
hibernating bats and they wake up on
their way down then they fly out
when they fly away it pulls a little rip
cord on them and on their chest was
stapled with a medical staple bag of
damn
uh about a 50 50 mixture of gasoline and
dish
soap to like napalm and they would go
into little japanese buildings and
there's a little chemical timer on it
and then they would
catch on fire burning four little bats
burning up all the buildings because
they would get up cool
they would get up in the nooks and
crannies and japanese wooden wooden
houses that was the idea
they made a whole damn target japanese
city to
town to test them on when they would it
would have worked
but it you got to raise a [ __ ] ton of
bats though and then you gotta keep them
[ __ ] their low temperature and you
gotta feed them
it's not plausible speaking of cruelty
to animals
um that was another that was another one
of the major differences between
the 1978 original and the 1995 remake
the 1978 original like keenan nguyen
is sitting there with his dog and he
gets his legs chewed off and he bleeds
to death
uh but the dog is okay i think the dog
doesn't get killed right i don't think
the dog gets killed
in the 1995 one the dog absolutely the
dog like jumps in the water trying to
save
its master and uh yeah so it doesn't do
it it doesn't do it i think it's a
golden retriever in the
remake and in the uh original i don't
know what kind of dog that is it was
just some kind of mutt dog
but yeah so so that was like the one
thing i was like oh [ __ ] you 95 movie
why don't you leave the dog alone you
can eat all the children you want for
[ __ ]
leave that poor puppy alone but yeah so
that was one thing that i wanted to
mention because that was kind of one
difference but yeah both uh the 1978
version and the 1995 version are both on
2b for free if you want to watch them
i still need to see the 2010 uh piranha
3d because i heard that was [ __ ]
crazy and like super over the top gory
and [ __ ] like that
and like i said piranha three double d
i'm sure you will enjoy that yeah
it's all just like like water but i saw
some like clips from it it looks
hysterical
more and more out of more and more
ridiculous yeah it's just supposed to be
like outlandish like tits and blood and
gore and you got like piranha
and 3d right is it 3d yeah
and then put some double d's in it yeah
yeah it's coming right now
all right how is that going to lose and
and like i said
you know having a scene where piranha
spits a dude's severed dick at you yeah
yeah
i mean how can that not be we could
watch them tonight
all right but yeah check them both out
they're on to be just fun 70s
animals attack movies jaws rip off but
it's good in its own right so yeah
that'll do it for
this movie retrospective and we will see
you guys on the next one
bye